just took a [ __ ] and there's this thing
and I wanted to vlog it going up my
butthole
hey I was go Bruce I'm on another trip I
know my life is so busy thank you very
much
I'm in Kuala Lumpur this place looks
amazing me and Myers had just slept like
20 hours from jet lag but we're finally
ready to head out I think we're gonna go
back somewhere what are you doing
get out of here go back to the cage
we're in the park that's our hotel I
kind of want to jump in and now we're
gonna go it's so [ __ ] hot
Jesus Christ we're gonna check out that
bridge the Tower was closed today so
we're gonna go tomorrow instead I feel
like I'm in the jungle so now we're
going to the aquarium oh my god
this is amazing look at all this this is
just a park
I just got recognized as well we've been
trying to keep this us being here a
secret because I know I have a lot a lot
of bros here and I'm actually really
scared of getting mobbed
especially since last time I was in
Singapore a win way out of hand
oh yeah this is so cool oh my god that
is terrifying
it's like slime coming down hi
oh my god I don't like this one always
looking at my crunch oh no oh no so cute
I like these more than the snake oh my
god that's disgusting
they look like Jax penis well I guess
there's no fish around here I can't seem
to see any of the fishes
these are so freaky it's too many
tentacles man okay guys what's going on
here
more charger
this is some alien shape
we are on a treadmill going so fast oh
my god it scared me it literally scared
me oh my god they're everywhere that's
an found you
well I think this one ate too much that
is some sexy [ __ ] just took a [ __ ] and
there's this thing and I wanted to vlog
it going up my butthole
I got a lien factor no there we go they
have these tunnel to walk through not to
worry oh thank you my Stan it's amazing
you can just get anywhere now we're
going to check out some shopping holy
[ __ ] it's Fashion Week we're here for
Fashion Week
now everyone is going to comment about
that but I'm sorry okay
so we're looking for Japan town while
we're in Malaysia
all right we found it
this is either driving Malaysia this is
how they drive in New York my favorite
vinyl figure Steve Jobs I think we're
about to die if the lights not working
okay let's go driving here is a little
crazy so if I haven't announced it
already
the next PewDiePie game is coming out
very soon it's been in development for
almost a year it is really cool
I broke Twilight it so you know it's
legit it's called PDP tuber simulator
and it will be a free game for your
phone we wanted to call it you tubers
simulator but we weren't allowed for
legal reasons it's really weird I know
there's been a lot of youtubers
simulator type of games lately but we
like I said we have this game in
development for over a year now before
all these other ones came out we thought
it was okay because this game is so
different like it's the same concept but
it's such a different game it's just a
really fun game and I'm happy that we
made a free game because that's was the
biggest feedback that we got for
pewdiepie legend on the brofist it's out
of minds who made it as well as same
developer you can tell again they did an
amazing job because the game is so so
great it's a very creative game so I'm
really excited to see what you bros are
gonna make of it yeah that's all for now
we pick like the gloomy as day
but it's very cool oh my god it's just
so weird we're moving that the whole
tower is moving can you tell it's so
hard to tell though you can barely tell
okay the tower isn't moving we're moving
okay this is scary
oh my god okay let's get some food you
finding anything good you're spying on
naked people in hotel that's where we
went
it looks like a giant disco ball what
are you doing my dad
okay we're going for our late late
afternoon swimming it's so [ __ ] hot
even at night it's so hot well this is a
really nice pool and there's no one
around
oh it feels good I feel pretty good
right now
it's a very nice place yes where I will
come from okay okay yes that's the right
oh no it's for my tenant you
Wow
you know these wooden right here my name
that was pretty nice there day two in
Kuala Lumpur today we're gonna do some
museum I mean there's a lot of cool
places around this area and we're
starting with this one do you want to go
on the escalator this looks really good
I guess we'll wash we decided to walk to
the next park and I'm starting to think
it was a bad idea this is crazy
we're going there this area feels so
weird because there's no one around and
I kind of don't really know where we are
but hopefully we'll make it there we're
about to enter the Jurassic Park bird
park the bird park oh my god
all right
I spotted some birds hi I like [ __ ]
people [ __ ] this place
lick my chest love bird
she literally didn't hear me look at
that
that's awesome oh my god what is
happening
oh they spit hi guys what's going on oh
yeah this is the squid oh whoa what
happened ah legit got scared
whoa look at you fancy I've got a
[ __ ] stick you better not touch me
man cuz I got a stick a channel sucks by
the way there's too many buddies too
much to take in
oh my god this is so cool look at that
guy looking very wise and this one he's
got his own little house going Oh Evan
that one so cute looks so happy like
they even got a freaking eagle or Birds
do they not have only I could be outside
that I'd be happy what did you find
oh my god please scare me hey how you
doing
her washer sleeping how you doing oh hey
oh that's too close thank you
pretty then I'm a little scared
get these birds look of love it's scary
but I want to go and say hi to my friend
next up the guy here I won't touch you
if you don't touch me you look like you
could take out my eyes you wanted to
that's why I'm wearing these by the way
this guy's just like more or your
[ __ ] wall
you talking to me man I should just go
I'm embarrassing myself let's fry you
better keep walking that's right you
better [ __ ] keep walking [ __ ] now
we're finally gonna go to the towers
bana
I don't know if it's even worth it since
we saw the view yesterday whenever I see
someone else blonde here I'm like what
are you doing I'm the only blonde one in
Kuala Lumpur not even blonde wow you see
the Park tonight so we're gonna go even
higher up twice as high as this in a
baby I'm on top of the world
mmm
we are now at the very top but I haven't
seen the view
we are really high right now this is a
little scary to be this high oh my god I
feel sick I feel like we're moving I
don't know I feel like I need to hold on
to something
I got tiny the people down there are
this really is amazing we're back we're
gonna chill by the pool event we are
getting recognized so much like I said
we didn't tell anyone we were coming
because we were a little scared about it
and people are definitely picking up
that we're here like it's most of my
tweets is about like where is he
what is put up I is in Malaysia I know
we should move Asian I'm still worried
that it's gonna get out of hand because
I get Singapore flashbacks so far it's
been ok but we had to stuff a lot of
times today a lot of people don't want
just one picture they want like three
pictures with different angles and we're
just kind of like we you're not the
first one we met okay that's all my
phone it's not going to break and ruin
all the footage but I'm going to show my
see at underwater
we're at times where something it's
really cool because they have a freaking
indoor rollercoaster which I've seen on
picture before but it's really crazy oh
my god
they have a freaking Lou
that's awesome
I will go on it for sure I have to go
that's crazy
the video does not do this place justice
it's really cool
should I go on in my tan okay I'll think
I'll go on and I'll buy a ticket
that was like the unsafest roller
coaster I ever felt like I was scared
because I thought I would die oh it's on
we're doing the cars this feels like a
theme park which oh well oh my god
oh I like this
oh you crazy I was gonna be nice what's
happening no come on
my car's not moving no mine says car
went into flames when she drove it I
told you this park is crazy
there's no it's not security there's
really no one here there's no one on any
of the right okay well what should be
doing in there I don't know you might
even get to put on my seat back they
just started this is so cool I love this
ride this is my favorite ride I love it
I love dancing so much it makes me feel
good thank you feel incredible
okay last day in Kuala Lumpur we're
going to the baths two caves which is
one of the holiest Hindu places outside
of India let's check it out okay so we
have 272 steps to me and I got a move
we're gonna walk all the way up that's a
golden statue not a big deal there's a
loser trying to blog it it's really hot
it doesn't show in the video but it's
really hot I'm really excited this is so
different how big is look at that that's
crazy
time to begin this test walk begins now
oh no you can rent a SCAF
I like the reference pictures
businesswomen
I might say it's getting tied up these
are very steep steps very small and very
high but we will make it up there oh my
god that it that does that feels a lot
more right now I feel like I could fall
backwards at any moment
I got you might see em don't worry good
exercise for sure see people stopping
taking breaks on the way
look we barely gone anywhere we'll make
it I'm sure almost there
this is so cool there's a chicken
alright
and there's the temple I guess we'll
walk here
oh there's monkeys look good dude don't
trust me one second this is how it looks
like it's very cool but my favorite
thing is chicken oh man I didn't mean
look at the temple it's like oh this is
freaking go spiders
on second thought maybe I won't go in
here now we just got to walk all the way
down it said that it was gonna rain
every single day we came here any get it
yeah until now it's raining oh my god oh
my god it's so much water
it's barely raining but we're kind of
into it okay once again we go into the
towers for a cinema as you do in another
country too bad you're not coming [ __ ]
we're leaving Kuala Lumpur today this
little one got sick he last night we
have to call a doctor at 3:00 a.m. it's
so much more quiet now like the weekend
was crazy we really felt like everyone
was hunting to find us here
it's barely anyone' and it feels so much
more relaxed it's time to end this vlog
Malaysia I had a such a great time such
a cool city Kuala Lumpur I really really
enjoyed it this is probably a bit longer
vlog do you have so much traffic ahead
of us Jesus I hope you enjoyed it even
though it was a little bit a little bit
longer thanks to all the really nice
fans that we met in Malaysia Shanna told
the Malaysian Broce you guys are intense
leave it like if you want more vlogs
like this and I'll be sure to vlog
whenever I go somewhere and thanks for
watching stay awesome press I have the
glasses I bet you thought the vlog was
over our flight got canceled it's 4:00
in the morning 4:30 our flight was
supposed to go at 11:00 which is like
late enough already we waited three
hours British Airways by the way I want
my money back the bag topology this is
so crazy
but I understand things get wrong but no
one knew how to deal with it like no one
told us what to do no one told us
anything I booked this in on the next
flight with another airline which is in
five hours we're gonna spend the night
at the airport the other option was to
sit on a bus and I called British
Airways they couldn't tell me anything
they couldn't say
thing they said there wasn't even a
flight tomorrow and we really need to go
back because our dog sitter needs to
can't take care of the dogs any longer
and it's such a huge problem because
they cancel this flight but we'll make
it back home it's so crazy I was getting
fully triggered for a while
looks like
sharing a bed tonight we try to say it
out in town so we could sleep at least a
couple hours but it was full so we're
staying here for I don't know I'm so
tired
I took a sleeping pill on the plane was
supposed to leave six hours ago
I can't it's so tired this has been a
nightmare we've been here for almost 10
hours British Airways [ __ ] it up big
time we've been so desperate of trying
to get home go home the the flight that
I booked was cancelled I don't like
everything is just gone wrong but we
managed to get on a flight thanks to
paying a lot of money and my dad and
because my car didn't work we're going
home now that's all that matters
[ __ ] British Airways honestly all
airlines they all suck like this could
have been any airline the